En otros videos comenzamos a hablar sobre los
tipos de enlaces que pueden formarse entre
átomos de ciertos elementos. Por ejemplo,
si tenemos dos metales formando un enlace,
bueno, vamos a tener un enlace metálico; si
tenemos dos no metales involucrados en alguna
actividad enlazante es probable que se trate
de un enlace covalente, y la regla general es:
si tienes un metal y un no metal, es probable que
se trate de un enlace iónico. Estas son las reglas
generales. Lo que quiero hacer en este video es
que se logre apreciar mejor que los enlaces en
realidad son un espectro. Hemos hablado de enlaces
covalentes polares que comienzan a verse un poco
más iónicos en la naturaleza, y de eso hablaremos
en este video. Piénsenlo en el contexto de la
electronegatividad. Sólo como recordatorio, ya
hablamos de electronegatividad en muchos videos:
ésta es la propiedad que tiene un átomo
en un enlace para acaparar electrones,
para que la densidad electrónica esté más cerca
y así dos pares de electrones pasen más tiempo
alrededor de ese átomo en particular. Así que
algo con una alta electronegatividad tiene mayor
capacidad de atraer electrones que algo con
baja electronegatividad. Podemos pensar en el
espectro entre iónico, en este extremo, y, en este
extremo, covalente. Y una forma de verlo es que en
el extremo izquierdo no hay mucha diferencia
en electronegatividades, los dos átomos que
participan en el enlace son aproximadamente
iguales en cuanto atraen los electrones;
mientras que en un enlace iónico tienes una
gran diferencia en electronegatividades,
tanto que uno de los átomos toma un electrón
del otro. De modo que una forma de pensar en
esto es... Voy a dibujar una pequeña flecha aquí
que aumenta la diferencia de electronegatividad a
medida que avanza de izquierda a derecha, y en
algún punto entre éstos, o a medida que avanza
de izquierda a derecha, se vuelve cada vez más
covalente polar. Así que, por ejemplo, si tienes
un enlace entre oxígeno e hidrógeno, ambos son
no metales, así que será un enlace covalente por
nuestra regla general. En realidad hasta aquí
llega la división entre metales y no metales,
esta línea azul que puedes ver es la división,
aunque las cosas que están alrededor de ellas
son un poco más interesantes. Entonces el oxígeno
y el hidrógeno son no metales, pero tienen una
gran diferencia en las electronegatividades. Esto
que tenemos aquí es electronegatividad medida en
una escala de Pauling, llamada así por el famoso
biólogo y químico Linus Pauling, y en esa escala
puedes ver que el oxígeno es 3.44, uno de los
átomos más electronegativos. Las tendencias de
electronegatividades de las que hablamos en otros
videos van de la parte inferior izquierda hacia la
parte superior derecha; los elementos en la parte
superior derecha que no son los gases nobles, son
los que realmente tienen más capacidad para atraer
electrones, y el oxígeno es uno de los que tiene
más capacidad, mientras que la electronegatividad
del hidrógeno no es nula pero es más baja, 2.20.
De modo que en este escenario esos electrones
van a pasar más tiempo alrededor del oxígeno;
si pasaran la misma cantidad de tiempo ese oxígeno
sería neutro, pero como pasan un poco más tiempo
aquí diremos que tiene una carga parcial negativa.
La letra griega minúscula delta [ δ] y en el lado
del hidrógeno, ya que los electrones compartidos
pasan más tiempo alrededor del oxígeno que del
hidrógeno, tenemos una carga parcial positiva,
así que esto sería un enlace covalente polar.
Tal vez en el espectro esté justo aquí,
dependiendo de cómo vemos esta escala. Ahora,
la otra pregunta que podríamos hacernos es:
bueno, este es un espectro entre covalente-iónico,
¿qué hay del metálico? Bueno, en general se van a
formar enlaces metálicos entre dos elementos que
no son tan diferentes en electronegatividad y que
tengan electronegatividades razonablemente bajas,
es por eso que si tienes dos elementos de la parte
inferior izquierda y éstos forman enlaces entre
ellos de alguna manera, es probable que sean
enlaces metálicos, y eso tiene sentido porque
en los enlaces metálicos todos los electrones
están mezclados en un tipo de piscina compartida,
lo que les da algunas de sus propiedades como
la conductividad. Y si tienes muchos elementos
bastante similares en electronegatividad
y que poseen baja electronegatividad,
podrían estar más dispuestos a compartir esos
electrones de valencia en una piscina comunitaria.